[Musique]
il ya deux éléments qui expliquent
l'intérêt de la turquie pour l'afrique
soulac et paix en particulier dans la
décennie 2010 le premier élément c'est
la politique étrangère global défendu
par l'atp qu'il voulait sortir de là du
simple alignement traditionnelle sur les
puissances européennes et occidentales
et acquérir une dimension globale
donc mondial donc se tourner vers
l'environnement l'environnement régional
proche le moyen-orient le caucase la
russie les balkans mais aussi vers un
environnement régional plus lointain
l'asie centrale par exemple et l'afrique
et sur ce plan la deuxième raison c'est
que vous avez un certain nombre de
conseillers de rédiger hyper doan qui
ont été des spécialistes de la situation
africaine et qui ont convaincu le
gouvernement aké paix de l'importance
stratégique de l'afrique
le président r doit lui-même est réputé
intéressés par cette question africaine
et donc à encourager le développement de
cette diplomatie turque vis-à-vis du
continent
[Musique]
il ya eu plusieurs phases les années
2000 ont aucune phase d' approche
progressive de l'afrique de redécouverte
de cet espace régional qui avait été
totalement négligé par la turquie le
tournant le vrai tournant ces 2011 la
turquie ouvre de très nombreuses
nouvelles ambassades en afrique ces
entreprises qui investissent vous avez
bien sûr l'exemple de la compagnie
turkish airlines par exemple l'atelier
national turquie ouvre énormément de
ligne vers l'afrique
jusqu'au coup d'état manqué de 2016 où
les relations deviennent plus
stratégiques
d'une part parce que le gouvernement
turc essaye de faire fermer les écoles
de son rival à fethullah gulen qui
étaient nombreuses en afrique et d'autre
part parce que avec l'échec de la
turquie au moyen-orient l'échec relatif
à un futur avec l'egypte des chèques en
syrie l'afrique acquiert une nouvelle
dimension stratégique en particulier la
corne de l'afrique la turquie à ce
moment et said approfondir ces relations
qui ne seront plus désormais seulement
commercial mais qui commence à prendre
une à tourner en plus stratégique et
politique avec même l'éventualité d'
accords militaires
à la cure qui investit beaucoup dans les
infrastructures dans le secteur du btp
dans le secteur de la construction par
exemple la construction de grands
bâtiments officiels la construction de
bâtiments administratifs
la restauration des routes les rails ce
sont des secteurs où la turquie d'une
part est traditionnellement plutôt forte
et d'autre part ce sont des secteurs
dans lesquels elle considère qu'il est
stratégique d'investir
un autre secteur ces deux secteurs
alimentaire parce que la turquie possède
beaucoup de firmes alimentaires
notamment deux firmes une distribution
qui voit en l'afrique un marché des
consommateurs intéressant et qui du coup
ont tendance à s'y implanter également
de la turquie aujourd'hui cherchent
l'autonomie stratégique par son armée et
c'est pour ça qu'elle essaye de
dynamiser ses partenariats en matière
d'armement en particulier les drones les
pays africains sont vus comme une
opportunité ce sont souvent des pays qui
peuvent être demandeur en matière
d'armement et la turquie fournit on va
dire des conditions de vente plus souple
que d'autres états
[Musique]
l'afrique a été la seule vraie réussite
de l'akp et la turquie a rencontré en
afrique beaucoup moins deux déconvenues
que vis-à-vis de l'europe ou du
moyen-orient il ya donc une dimension à
la fois symboliques parc et voir là où
on a réussi et par ailleurs une
dimension stratégique potentiel c'est à
dire que puisque il est difficile
aujourd'hui de conserver une zone
d'influencé au moyen-orient ou en europe
la turquie essaie au moins de peser à
l'échelle globale en renforçant son
influence pour d'autres régions dans
l'afrique
[Musique]
il faut noter que depuis les années
2016 2017 la politique de la turquie en
afrique devient moins confessionnelles
c'est à dire qu'elle était beaucoup
tourné auparavant vers les états
musulmans en particulier les états qui
est devenu un lien lointain avec l'
empire ottoman avec la perte du soudan
avec le retour en angleterre aux
affaires en turquie il ya une politique
plus pragmatique on a vu par exemple
pays se tourner vers l'ethiopie avec
cette affaire de ventes de drones
supposée aux éthiopiens et d'autre part
il y aventurent qu' une volonté
désormais s'ouvrir de nouveaux marchés
donc on a évoqué l'afrique de l'est
l'afrique de l'ouest pour l'instant le
point faible de la turquie vers la
stratégie turque en afrique c'est le
cône sud du continent qui est encore
relativement délaissés il ya un intérêt
tueur pour l'afrique du sud il ya une
volonté d'investir cet espace mais la
turquie encore beaucoup moins présentes
que dans la zone sahélienne et la corne
de l'afrique
[Musique]